Hello! I'm VOA's Rebecca Ward for Going Green.
Thanks for joining us today.
Where as you could see: It's as green as green can be.
School's out. Summer's in,...
...with kids all over the United States trading in their textbooks for less studious activities.
Except that is for hundreds of kids in Washington...
...who are learning firsthand about the environment they live in.
These tools work.
This is the District of Columbia's 2nd Annual Green Summer Youth Program.
And these kids are definitely going green.
So, the opportunity for the kids at the district...
...is they'll have a chance to get in on the green revolution at the ground floor,...
...right now, when it's just beginning to bloom.
It's a tremendous opportunity.
These are not work that you can't imagine yourself doing if you don't know enough about.
These are entry level to any kind of career. Everything is open.
George Hawkins is the director of the District Department of the Environment.
He is working with the mayor's office to teach inner city youth how to appreciate and care for their environment.